Depuis la nuit des temps,
nous levons nos yeux vers le ciel,
observant et rêvant des mondes
inconnus que pourrait abriter l'univers.
Imaginons que l'on puisse quitter la Terre,
et voyager à travers l'espace et le temps,
afin d'explorer ces mondes inaccessibles,
à la découverte du Cosmos.
Nous sommes à 1 milliard et demi
de kilomètres du Soleil.
Vue d'ici, notre étoile n'est plus qu'un point,
perdu dans l'immensité.
Devant nous se dresse Saturne.
C'est la sixième planète du système solaire.
Saturne est une immense boule de gaz.
Dix fois plus grande que la Terre, la géante gazeuse
mesure à elle seule près de 120 000 km de diamètre,
pour une masse de 500 000 trilliards de tonnes.
Se situant si loin du Soleil, elle met
près de 30 ans pour en faire le tour.
Ici, une année équivaut à 11 000 jours sur Terre.
L'atmosphère très épaisse de Saturne
est composée en majeure partie d'hydrogène,
auquel viennent s'ajouter un peu d'hélium,
et quelques traces d'autres gaz rares.
Ces gaz, très légers, procurent à Saturne
une densité moyenne très faible.
Si on pouvait la plonger dans un océan assez grand,
elle serait en mesure de flotter à la surface de l'eau.
Parcourue de couleurs jaunes et orangés, l'atmosphère de Saturne est loin d'être uniforme.
Sa couleur est due aux éléments
chimiques qui la composent.
Elle présente parfois des reflets bleus qui découlent
de phénomènes complexes liés à la diffusion de la lumière.
Ces mêmes phénomènes qui donnent
sa couleur azur à notre ciel sur Terre.
En surface, règne une température glaciale de -180°C.
Les nuages de gaz circulent autour de la planète, et forment un empilement de rayures horizontales.
Dans ce flux incessant, il arrive parfois
que se forment d'énormes orages.
Pouvant durer plusieurs mois, et
s'étendre sur des milliers de kilomètres,
ces tempêtes électriques, extrêmement puissantes, donnent lieu à des vents déchaînés,
qui peuvent atteindre des vitesses vertigineuses.
Au niveau du pôle Nord la course des vents
dessine un motif nuageux très étrange.
Sa mystérieuse forme, en hexagone,
n'a pour l'instant pas d'explication précise.
Si l'on pouvait filmer dans les ultraviolets, on pourrait
également distinguer de magnifiques aurores polaires.
Ces lueurs intrigantes, similaires à
celles que l'on trouve sur Terre,
proviennent de l'interaction des vents solaires
avec le champ magnétique de la planète.
Saturne est entourée d'un impressionnant
système d'anneaux concentriques.
Ces anneaux sont composés de fines particules
de glace et de poussière, qui gravitent autour de la planète.
Extrêmement fins, ils ne sont épais que de
quelques dizaines de mètres seulement,
contre une envergure de plusieurs
centaines de milliers de kilomètres.
L'origine de ces anneaux est encore un mystère.
Il pourrait s'agir d'une lune, qui se serait
aventurée trop près de la planète.
Tiraillée et déformée par l'attraction de Saturne,
elle aurait fini par exploser,
se faisant pulvériser par les forces de marrées.
Saturne est monstrueusement massive.
Son influence gravitationnelle très forte lui permet de
maintenir en orbite plus d'une soixantaine de lunes.
Certaines de ces lunes orbitent
à l'intérieur des anneaux.
C'est par exemple le cas de Pan.
En orbite au sein de la division d'Encke,
son attraction gravitationnelle dévie
la trajectoire des particules environnantes.
Le passage régulier du satellite permet ainsi
de maintenir cette division ouverte,
et de séparer les anneaux
qui lui sont situés de part et d'autre.
Voici Prométhée,
et Pandore.
Prométhée et Pandore sont deux satellites bergers,
qui travaillent de concert.
Situées sur des orbites très proches, les deux lunes
dévient la trajectoire des particules autour d'elles,
et les forcent à se confiner dans un anneau très étroit,
d'une centaine de kilomètres à peine.
En s'éloignant de Saturne et de ses anneaux,
il est possible de croiser la route
d'une grande variété de lunes,
présentant chacune des caractéristiques uniques.
A 240 000 km de Saturne, voici Encelade.
Plus petite que notre Lune, Encelade fait toutefois
partie des plus grands satellites de Saturne.
Lorsqu'on s'en rapproche, la lune
présente d'étranges panaches,
qui s'élèvent à plusieurs centaines de kilomètres,
au dessus de sa surface.
Composés de particules de glace, de gaz, et de
poussières, ces jets de matière proviennent de cryovolcans
parsemés à la surface du satellite.
Ils sont les témoins d'une
intense activité géologique interne.
En surface, Encelade est recouverte de glace,
criblée d'impacts, de cratères,
et entaillée de fissures et de failles volcaniques.
La lune reste constamment glaciale,
pouvant atteindre en moyenne -200°C.
Malgré cette température très faible en surface,
l'activité géologique d'Encelade trahit
l'existence d'un océan d'eau liquide sous la glace,
ainsi que la présence de composés organiques.
Deux ingrédients essentiels
pour le développement de la vie.
Nous sommes désormais à plus
d'un million de kilomètres de Saturne.
C'est à cette distance que se trouve
son plus grand satellite.
Titan.
Titan héberge un monde complètement
différent d'Encelade.
Englobé d'une atmosphère très dense, à base de diazote, on y trouve un climat très riche,
avec des nuages, des pluies de méthane,
ou encore des saisons, comme sur Terre.
Sous cette épaisse couche nuageuse, se cache une surface aux aspects variés,
qui peut faire penser aux paysages
que l'on trouve sur Terre.
Traversée de rivières et de lacs de méthane,
et parsemée de volcans, de montagnes,
et de dunes de sable.
Bien que glaciale à cette distance du Soleil,
Titan rappelle étonnamment les
premiers instants de notre planète.
La composition chimique de son atmosphère
présente des molécules organiques complexes,
qui peuvent faire penser aux conditions prébiotiques,
à l'origine de la vie sur Terre.
Visible depuis la Terre, elle est
observée depuis la préhistoire.
Saturne a depuis toujours fasciné les astronomes.
Sa taille imposante et ses anneaux grandioses
en font une merveille du système solaire.
Aujourd'hui mieux connue que jamais,
elle regorge cependant d'une myriade de mystères,
qu'il reste encore à découvrir.
[Vraies photographies]